what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation thank you so much for
clicking on this video we're gonna watch
the menu for the first time today John
how are you I am hungry for some Cinema
G how are you I'm good I'm good you know
what's on the menu today like buttons
leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated also full length Reaction
watch alongs where you sync up with your
own copy of the menu available for our
super sexy rejects over at our patreon
page over there we cover several shows
exclusively with reaction highlights and
watch alongs included I've heard only
good things about this movie and nothing
specific I think I saw a trailer for
This months ago in the theaters can't
tell you what I what I remember from it
Ray fines is in it it's all it's about
on them
let's get to it guys
[Music]
hey please don't smoke it'll kill your
palate tonight is huge okay the flavor
profiles it's all super delicate when
you smoke you ruin your ability to be
able to appreciate it
please
aren't I get where he's getting them
coming from actually
gonna love this
we are right after the races
just a good credit for civil war okay
well it's official tonight will be
Madness
you're not geeking out enough please
make yourselves comfortable for our
short journey to Hawthorne Island thank
you
and I've asked me hard Jesus hope she
see where the a yes both both jokes oh
yeah we're on a boat we're on a boat
Chef slow would like to welcome you with
a raw local oyster enemy on that
Emulsion it's one of his classics
lemon pearls are made with alginate
alginate is in
um as an algae come on you seem
insufferable Nicholas Holt
I relate to this guy it's the balance of
the products you need the mouth feel of
the minionette
please don't say a mouthful too late
mouth feel mouthful mouthful moist moist
moist
[Music]
welcome to Hawthorne Mr Ledford and Miss
Westervelt sorry yeah no that was uh
it's not miss what the change of plans
ouch
this is Miss
I'm Marco oh
[Music]
awkward gonna handle it differently man
yeah a million different ways
what are you working on now oh hey
thanks for asking see people still know
me
are you gonna wish the paparazzi was
here each day starts at six with five
hours of prep work we Harvest we ferment
we Slaughter we marinate we liquefy we
spherify we jump we gel
listen up Marco uh who lives there Chef
can we see that
even we are not allowed inside Chef's
Cottage
oh but we will go there surprised by how
immediate this movie is Miss
Mills Miss Mills you will be sitting in
this
I'm Never Gonna Let You live that down
oh God this is awkward please do not
photograph our dishes Chef strongly
feels that the beauty in his Creations
lies in their ephemeral nature in the
mouth feels
do you make that with a paco jet
exactly right sir yes
you know a paco jet can produce a
powderized snow-like texture cool
there he is
such a realistic way to introduce him
is he looking at me no he's looking at
not miss Westervelt I have to change the
whole menu
here we have a compressed and pickled
cucumber melon milk snow and chard lace
thank you Food Network
can you taste a little goat
it's right at the end a little kid she
said no first I would like to say thank
you for the last two years this
opportunity oh dude at least we're at
work
the working money yeah baby we're
pathetic aren't we yeah money work
Alphas the grind so what is it with this
food thing
I don't know it's like you know how
people idolize you know athletes and
musicians and Painters and stuff
those people are idiots
watched him explain the exact moment the
green strawberry is perfectly on ripe
I've watched him played a raw scallop
during its last dying contraction in
oscillates art on the edge of the Abyss
which is where God works too it's the
same that was beautifully put
time it was wonderfully put I'm being
serious I think I'm starting to get it
really really a little
I love very little
serve human flesh
nothing seems like it's off the table
[Music]
yes I just don't think I could eat
comfortably at a place like this it's
not about Comfort it's about art and
life and death and sacrifice
good evening
good evening I am Julian slowik and
tonight it'll be our pleasure to feed
you hey hey I have to beg of you one
thing it's just one
do not
eat
Savor relish
consider every morsel that you place
inside your mouth
be mindful
but do not eat our menu is too precious
for them
too much mouth feel
they must know more about everybody than
they let on
I care more about quantity and eating
until my stomach tells me you've had
enough what happens inside this room
is meaningless compared to what happens
outside in nature
in the soil and the water
like balls
enjoy
that
[Applause]
I thought he is crying
I find it all very moving it's also
beautiful I just it's almost too
beautiful to eat stop taking photos
I'm really feeling this is quite it's
half great it's there in moments they're
in moments
flavors are there it's very clean it's
very um
thalassic
elastic Oceanic thalasso was the
Primeval
spiritos yes yes so yeah you dumbass
yeah you idiot you like this the otter
fruit yeah it's salad I mean I've had
shelf is just as good with my chef at
home Ricardo you know Ricardo is amazing
okay oh my God you guys are all getting
Targets on your back
what is her deal
Fred has existed in some form for over
12 000 years peasants dip their stale
measly Bread and Wine for breakfast
Jesus teach us to pray if not to beg for
our daily bread overachiever
but you my dear guests are not the
Common Man and so tonight
you get no bread
what I love bread yeah what what gives
half the reason I go to Cheesecake
Factory is for the bread bottomless no
bread this Emulsion does look slightly
split
oh golly I mean I was gonna say cut his
head off yep serve them as the next
course in the restaurant of this quality
There It Is Well there it is yeah oh my
God I mean it's next level badasser
he's not just a chef he's a he's a
Storyteller and he doesn't give a [ __ ]
about the rules only the girl next door
but maybe there are some rules that you
should give up about like I don't know
giving food to people at a restaurant
there is no one would ever call you the
Girl Next Door Nicholas Holtz has now
morphed into my favorite character
well I can just love his positive
attitude about it all
[Music]
singled out you talk a little loud
um I mean look the food's great and we
totally get all the conceptual stuff but
could we please get a little bread you
know and some gluten-free for my friend
as well no yikes I know who you are
influencer you know we work with Doug
Barrick right flip is a little bread
please we won't tell a soul lady yeah I
promise okay no foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
star pupil
you haven't touched your food
there is no food yes do I want to fill
up that would not be possible I've
precisely designed the portions to
account for that so you won't fill up
the menu only makes sense if you eat but
you told us not to eat
that is not what I meant Madam you know
it yeah
well thank you for your concern but I am
perfectly capable of deciding when I eat
and what
you're embarrassing him Mario
in front of the patriarchy all right
that was humiliating humiliating yeah
Tyler the guy's a prick oh too loud
this whole situation is just awkward yep
next course is called memory and that is
what is meant to evoke so let me tell
you a memory of mine when I was growing
up a child in Waterloo Iowa Tuesday was
taco night oh yeah Taco Tuesday
this is my mother
hey when I was seven years old one
Tuesday my father came home quite drunk
my mother grew angry and screamed at him
at which point he proceeded to wrap a
telephone cord around her neck and pull
it tight what is this story he's gonna
serve the telephone cord well I finally
had to stab him in the thigh with
kitchen scissors
wow
this is a Macabre meal I hope everyone
gets to remember some traumatic memories
right now
how smoked breast chicken thigh al
pastor and our own tortillas made with
heirloom mask the images on the
tortillas have been made using a laser
engraving machine it's the first time
we've used it oh no oh no they like
personal memories printed on the
tortillas
that sounds like it they're restaurants
that I reviewed that all closed
like a gag it's like Chef jigsaw it's a
very emotional dinner it's very
personalized me oh that's why Margo's
throwing the whole thing off
um
Tyler is that you
they're on me from tonight taking photos
Dr Sunshine dumb part bad script one
shoot though right
um
whoa
what the hell are these These are
tortillas
these are tortillas which contain
echobright's tax records and other
documents showing how your company has
created invoices with fake charges
whoa who is that woman uh oh damn it
I was hoping it wouldn't be it's faint
it's some sort of sort of stupid joke
Taco okay can't hurt you yeah and taco
that might hold up in court so eat the
evidence hey I have to make this right
somehow I have to well I'll tell you how
you make it right you send this [ __ ]
back excuse me excuse me sir hi
oh he snapped oh I don't snap no and I
don't really care send [ __ ] back to this
kitchen
oh child
this is incredible you have to try this
no thanks
thanks don't let me interrupt
damn that was cold dude oh boy
cigarette is ruining the taste you're
barely eating the food why why do you
care I take my work very seriously and
you're not eating
and that wounds me
if you put the cigarette out and move
out of nose nah blow smoke in his face
who are you I am Marco you shouldn't be
here tonight
please get the [ __ ] out of my way yikes
are you trying to save you
it's like the one audience member in
your stand-up crowd who's not laughing
yeah
Jeremy created the next dish it's called
the mess he's good
he's very good enough but he's not great
God
do you like this life this life that
you've dreamed about
no chef and do you want my life Wow
no sure
well it's just another day for Greg and
John Yep this is how we start out John
do you want my life
Jeremy's the mess
please wow
oh
damn I did not see that coming
wow
I didn't see that coming
um
what is that this is an exclusive
experience please
thank you so much
and now they're gonna wrap them up and
roast him in that they're gonna put him
in a giant smoker or something
this is what he does it's part of the
menu
enjoy your femur bone questioning what's
in that huh
you cheer me I want a refund
there is no boat to leave on then I'll
call a helicopter that would be very
difficult without phone service
just with which hand will you handle
this left or right oh no oh crazy I'm
gonna cut off your hand choose what
very well left hand
ring finger oh my God
please hold still
straight to the point
please [ __ ]
Jesus Christ it's all part of the menu
okay I honestly think that this whole
thing is just for our benefit I mean oh
that's why he texted me ugh
Chef slowly would like to see you in the
kitchen
can I come too
absolutely not sir
can I come too this menu this guest list
this entire evening has been
painstakingly planned and you are not a
part of that plan and it's spoiling
everything is it now proceed I have to
know where to seat you
with us or with them oh and then you'll
let me live that you live no
we're all going to die tonight
do you want to die with those who give
or with those who take please pick
die a giver in 15 minutes
I'll take a break between courses and
that is how long you have to decide I
give her
I mean you wouldn't know how to cook
though oh my God what if Nicholas holds
like yeah I know we're gonna die yeah
that's why it's the whole reason I
signed up unfair why do you get a
kitchen of course
smoke all day can't even taste it
oh
we have better knife skills than that
what other choice do we have
um
oh boy no you're not
I mean I would first try to take out the
guards and stuff right please let me
without you
[Laughter]
don't worry you can always go back to
your Comedy Central show
any questions
Bergamot I'm getting a chef
yes it is
beautiful
we we want to know what the [ __ ] is this
happening man well I'll tell you think
of yourselves as ingredients in the degu
station concept Miss Bloom knows the
damage she has done to so many
livelihoods no no no no hang on no no no
no you don't talk
how many times have you eaten here in
the last five years 11 times Mr librand
kindly name one dish you ate the last
time you were here oh my God tell me one
dish you ate the last time you were here
for the time before
not bread Cod
it wasn't caught you donkey
I've allowed my work to reach the price
point where only the class of people in
this room can access and I've been
fooled in trying to satisfy people who
could never be satisfied that that's our
culture isn't it and my restaurant is
part of the problem uh I would have to
say that Doug Varick owns me except now
things a little more complicated and I
own Doug Varick
[Music]
what's going on oh my when he questioned
my menu you would even request
substitutions despite the fact that
there are no substitution the whole
fallen angel please
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's cool do you hear
do you hear it
do you hear that silence listen can you
hear it
and standing on every word
we thought I couldn't tell oh I know a
fellow service industry worker when I
see one Mr librand how do you know him
you've been eyeing him all evening oh I
think you know oh no
what rattled me is that he told me to
tell him that he was a good man and that
I was his daughter and that he left me
and I loved him
he's a romantic yeah that's what I would
put oh do you enjoy providing your
services do you enjoy providing yours I
haven't desired to cook for someone in
ages and one does miss that feeling oh
they're connecting cook for Margot the
next course let us take the evening air
come on outside we should create some
type of immersive experience out of this
yeah that wouldn't go wrong in any way
shape or form
don't be frightened nothing to be
frightened of so maybe there's a spirit
building somewhere we can get out of
here what red dead it's okay no we're
gonna die tonight yeah
such a Yes Man
Julian sloark tried to fight me I
refused he kept me in his kitchen and
refused to look me in the eye speak
directly to me for eight months cold our
next course is called man's folly
we will be serving sausage and eggs God
I mean he's like what to our male diners
we now offer you the chance to escape
you'll be given a 45 second head start
at which point members of my staff will
try and catch you if they do catch
laughs
holy [ __ ] what hold this
I'll send for help first thing
not such a beast after all Nicholas Holt
I have no clue where this is going nope
even Chef is not
morally Superior
go
it is the most dangerous game
this is fantastic the tartness of the
umaboshi and the the waves of ferment
it's it's rich and yet it's clean it's
delicious
[Music]
better it's so good it's really good
Jesus
let's go
you know my husband
foreign
it doesn't work if you live
what doesn't work the menu I mean really
you should have your own place right and
I could help you with that
clever
oh everyone dying with my pitch actually
oh God
anybody want anyone yes
thank you
[Music]
definitely keep your voices down foreign
special bite for the last guest to be
caught
of course
what did you do out there I'm the only
one who got away
I'm sorry I'm a failure
it's okay
I've been stealing money for me
oh wow yeah I know I'm afraid I'm in you
cannot continue as planned until we deal
with an unresolved matter it's got bread
tell me why you're here I wanted to
experience your food chef what were you
told ahead of time be the greatest menu
ever created right and and that everyone
would die oh my God you asked what yes
you brought manga that's just because
you don't offer ceilings for one so you
hired her knowing she'd die wow
yes yes ma'am
you're a cook Cooks belong in the
kitchen come with me
psychopath
nope Tyler now cook
I don't cook look Tyler Jesus man damn
it man Charlotte for the great foodie
the phenomenal Mr Food himself everyone
gather around they must learn from Tyler
this is a new uh a new dice oh poor guy
as much as I hate you poor guy
I bear witness to a revolution in
Cuisine
protein
no you're missing all the basics gradual
man
you're gonna like burn himself or
something let's be like son of Rich
parents or some [ __ ] huh it's actually
quite
bad
[ __ ]
[Music]
you are why the mystery has been drained
from our art
[Music]
go climb in the oven Tyler
dessert requires a large barrel that is
supposed to be there in the corner Margo
you will fetch the barrel instead give
her the SmokeHouse key
Elsa Elsa Elsa you had one job I just
don't think it's really fair you want to
know why you're being punished I saw the
film calling Dr sunshine I did not enjoy
it I didn't direct it I just acted in it
the memory of your face in that film
and what about her
what school did you go to
Brown student loans
I'm sorry you're dying
wow
[Music]
that's cool it's like a replica no one
is allowed inside Chef's house
do you think you're special
oh usually there's a knife there
trust me I have no idea
you have all kinds of items there yep
get a pan
[Music]
coaching he didn't tell me talk about
the barrel I didn't forget
oh geez
[Music]
you have a chance to survive come on
Aaron yeah yep yep
[Music]
nope
[Music]
hello
happy birthday oh geez
you told them it was my birthday seemed
funny about three hours ago thank you
as Dr King said we know through painful
experience that freedom is never
voluntarily given by the oppressor it
must be demanded by the oppressed he
just caught Martin Luther King
sure did
[Laughter]
clear the dining room immediately
oh
why would you return they planned for
this ask yourselves two things one if
you really want to be responsible for
the death of an innocent man and two ask
yourselves this entire evening
why didn't you all try harder to fight
back huh
I could have fought all them did anybody
here call in a distress over the
shortwave tonight
notice the injured guy uh are you
I'm a big fan
thank you would you like this autograph
I don't want to bother you oh no no no
help me
just don't say you love that movie that
the chef hates
my wife and I we love that oh what's it
called the one where you play the
surgeon yeah
calling Dr Sunshine yeah thank you so
much
go react to the note oh thank you for
your service
hands on your head everyone
my God what's coming from behind the
window on your knees with your hands
over your head now
yeah now
no
damn it
no
thank you death thank you
oh God he's [ __ ] me so I'm in the
kitchen we all work together and nothing
works at all
[Laughter]
you've betrayed our sacred Bond of trust
shown your craft
to be careless oh my God cut his throat
final course plating in five
you can take some of them right if they
like really band together
use some of the objects around you
[Music]
I don't like your food and I would like
to send it back
every dish you served tonight has been
some intellectual exercise rather than
something you want to sit and enjoy true
true
it tastes like it was made with no love
oh this is ridiculous we always cook
with love don't we
laughs
I thought tonight was a night of hard
home truth this is one of them you cook
with Obsession not love
your single purpose on this Earth is to
serve people food that they might
actually like and you have failed you
failed and you've bored me the worst
part is I'm still hungry
you know what I'd really like
tell me Burger
a cheeseburger not me no we can do a
cheeseburger
laughs
how do you like it medium American
cheese because it melts without
splitting how much will that set me back
9.95
[Music]
a crinkle cut Julian curly fries
everything oh my God is it's gonna bring
him back to the love Yeah making it
himself come on Carmi cook with passion
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the most lovely cooking sequins
too
[Music]
how happy he looks
not a roughly plate and all
[Music]
damn them fries look good
[Music]
I would have asked for that onions I'll
take your onions boy
give me all the onions
no that
is a cheeseburger unfortunately I think
my eyes were a little bigger than my
stomach don't push it can I get the rest
to go
[Music]
clever girl one moment please
[Music]
one cheeseburger to go
thank you for dining at Hawthorne oh my
God
thank you for um
for a couple bucks
you played well
um
oh
boy you still can so once again
thank you for dining with us tonight you
represent the ruin of my art oh
now you get to be a part of it
part of what I hope is my
masterpiece
are they gonna burn the place down I
hope so let's go yes just go ahead and
roll around in those coat yourself
foreign
[Music]
's a s'more
[Music]
as made of chocolate
you must embrace the flame
[Music]
yeah cast iron hands
like Mars or Heretics we can be subsumed
Anew thank you
I love you all
I even they're saying it
oh no
damn oh
don't go no it's gonna blow up yeah
it's gonna be filled with graham
crackers and marshmallows
customers staff at restaurant that's
great
laughs
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well done oh she got away
Adam McCain wolf Ferrell's company
produces huh
bam
sure I told them
okay that was a movie that was oof that
was a satire if ever there was the lower
class wins people
yeah man lower class wins they come out
on top who needs old-fashioned
cheeseburger sex worker gets to come out
on top of some talking about baby right
yeah all you filthy rich disgusting
Pricks that was your fake high class
sensibility yeah you'll go down in
flames you know or a bunch of petty
[ __ ] and the irony of s'mores Poor
People's food
yeah that's what they call it you should
be so lucky is to let the poor Eat You
Alive
that was uh that was delicious no pun
intended all that food looked not
appetizing not gonna lie and did not
want to eat any of them
a couple I had no no flavor for it I was
like I would never eat this
I don't know I like quantity
poor mans you want yeah you want
quantity of food I want to I want
something cheap and a bunch of crap
cheeseburgers flavor
[ __ ] Munch and then and his weight
takes like 20 30 minutes for your
stomach to tell you're full and then
just keep eating until that signal comes
in and you eat till you like hate life
that's the way to do it if you're gonna
pay that much money for food all right
that's that's what I'm getting at with
this yeah 12.50 ahead or whatever I was
surprised by how uh quick and immediate
it was uh just normally with these
horror films it's like there's kind of
it was funnier than I expected it to be
I mean I didn't know what the genre of
filming was but I would classify this as
like a horror dark horror comedy I I
feel like it's in really it's it's
intentionally funny it's like a lot of
black comedy yeah yeah it was funny it
was a really funny film absolutely and I
was surprised by how funny it was uh I I
thought it would be because you know
that's reminding you of like a lot of
the
like you were trying to name off oh yeah
ready or not earlier all right yeah yeah
ready or not you want to call it hide
and seek but yeah ready or not no radio
silence hide and seek Robert De Niro
it's uh Ready or Not uh there are
flavors of
all those kind of things I thought I was
gonna go down to your next route it was
not a your next route
oh yeah some kind of like bloody all-out
like survival thing yeah yeah I think
Ready or Not is probably the more apt
title descriptor
for it and then of course you got films
very recent like don't worry darling to
a certain extent
really uncomfortable dinner scene that
take place uh in this offshoot Island
there's oh I think there's a bunch of
movies you can name yeah that yeah this
is a type of movie but it's a good cat
and mouse type of game with Ray fines
and Anya Taylor Joy uh that I really
enjoyed I thought it was really fun I
like its political social commentary a
classism uh and it it didn't feel like
overtly I mean I would say it's pretty
overt it didn't feel overly bogged down
by it it seemed like the game was the
front and center of the show it didn't
get lost in the commentary especially
because Rey finds a chef is is [ __ ]
insane
he's he's nutso so I'm never like
listening to him going man's got a point
he's got a good point you know yeah even
even in times where it threatens to push
you out into that direction the movie
does bring him down to either pettiness
or some other self-serving and like I
like the way that Ray finds really
strikes the balance of like this is
truly a guy who believes that he is
humbling himself and giving up his ego
and yeah and making this Grand example
and yet there is still this sort of
shriveled Petty guy at the center of
that and I like that this movie because
he's lording he's the puppet master of
this whole show this whole charade I
like that the movie doesn't actually try
to maintain that he
is some kind of moral Authority in this
little bubble like it humanizes him too
and I think that that helps I think it
drastically helps otherwise it would
have felt like the movie's preaching it
to me as if he's some type of
social justice story
yeah yeah some kind of Jigsaw type guy
he was like he's doing it the wrong way
but he's got the right ideas you know
like yeah I mean I I think they managed
to make with this Chef character Chef
slowik uh they they managed to make the
movie
surprisingly character driven even when
you're not in his perspective this whole
thing is sort of from his perspective
because you see that he comes from a
troubled past sounds like he came from a
poor past and then as he rose through
the ranks and rooster ladder like he
talks about how his business flourished
or it now only caters to the definition
of like the 0.5 percent out there
and what has become of his art and what
has become of him and and everything
he's talking about is the deterioration
of of him and the reflection of that
through the customers that he has so
it's not some type of to me I didn't
read it as preachy even though the film
clearly has that imbued in there it
doesn't feel like I'm being talked at
because it's all sounding like this is
all from the character of the chef and
this is the world point of view that we
have all gotten suckered into because of
him and so it makes sense why someone
like Margot who or Aaron whatever her
name is you know seeing a I thought that
was clever seeing the photo of what he
was you know once a really happy guy who
did it out of love and with the burgers
yeah yeah that was clever and then to
order for the burger remind him of the
love for that and then asking for that
to go or I'm like oh you brought back a
nostalgic memory rod and it got you out
of here you clever clever ass poor girl
you found a way to win the unwinnable
game yeah yeah it was it was smart it
was it was really smart and I love the
the cult-like manipulation of uh like
it's the the restaurant represents uh a
sort of mindset of society and I really
like that a lot yeah no I'm surprised by
this movie it was funnier and faster
than I expected some people I feel like
my categorize has a slow burn but I
don't think it was slow it was more like
I don't know where it's going but
you know and once you get to the like
the guy who um uh trying to watch my
words here
there's this the shoe Chef the suit the
sushi sous chef
and then they're like okay this is
interesting yeah but I was I was into it
of of like I like the horror movies like
I don't know what's happening here you
know but I'm really into the fact that I
could tell something bad's gonna go down
like like movies like the invitation and
[ __ ] like that where again isolated
location and you know like murders
around the corner you know yeah yeah
absolutely I thought this did nicely I
think you yeah like it's not overtly a
cult thing but it is and I think that's
part of the the fun of the genre and the
commentary is the cult that forms around
the chef both in the kitchen and outside
of the kitchen and the cult that can
grow around like you know people who
just have opinions and authorities and
are you know given platform enough to
put them out there at will and you know
pull the strings of other people's lives
like I liked I liked what this made of
itself and I like the deliberate quality
of it because I mean yeah it is
I almost like that we don't have to open
on some kind of like preliminary
prologue sequence or something like that
it throws you in and it doesn't
necessarily like obviously Margot is the
cipher but she's not even like a hundred
percent us which I appreciate because
funny enough throughout this I I was
often reminded of hide and seek and I
think what I liked murderer
ready or not
someday I like I like that movie and I
heard a lot of people being like Oh man
like it's so sharp with the class
commented but that was the movie that
felt like it was kind of putting it in
my face whereas this I I appreciated
that it kind of just plops a bunch of
characters together and it gives you
this structure and a power set but also
it kind of just lets you look at and
draw your conclusions about anyone and
everyone and I love that certain things
are the morality play like the husband
and wife and like oh he's been seeing it
just so happens that the same prostitute
he hired is here
um but then you have stuff like genre
guzama where it's just like I went to
your movie on my one day off and I
freaking hated it and too often well it
was beyond that it was the it was the
fact that your passion is gone yeah yeah
it was yeah it was like watching one of
those actors yeah and and but even that
like I I appreciate that even within
that there is a certain level of there
there is a philosophy to it but it is
like a pettier thing on the hierarchy of
concerns that are happening in this room
and I thought it added a lot of it just
added a lot of like human color that
made all the characters feel very human
even though the situation is so
heightened and I thought that the way
they stylized the characters was good
because everyone's pretty distinct and
there are certainly very dark comedic
choices but no one's playing too much of
a big character like even Nicholas Holt
who is like kind of the biggest joke the
whole time because like far past the
point and it's it's Justified because he
knows
technically about the deaths although
even in that scene I'm like does he know
that it really means they're gonna die
like how much seriousness was stressed
to this guy but even with him even the
way that he is constantly just eating up
this guy's words far past the point
where everyone else is like this is
messed up you know I get spoiled rich
kid who never had to work for anything
um from him sure like that's like the
whole vibe yeah and an armchair expert
who's never actually done the thing for
real and never actually cared to you
know put their not that you have to
become a master of anything and
everything you talk about but at the
same time it seems like to Grant the
true appreciation you would have to try
well yeah and I think it's part of the
commentary of the film is people feeling
like they're never gonna be good enough
no matter what Heights they achieve and
I think the kitchen setting you know
with Ray finds sort of being the image
that you know kind of associated with
like a Gordon Ramsay where it is like a
it feels like a whatever you see
anything like that it feels like a
church yeah like he is Lord and
everything else everyone it's like
prostrate before him yeah that's what I
hear of like what it's like being in a
ballet school you know everything is it
feels like a religion in a way and and
it's a constant fear of discipline and
of being disciplined and not rising to
be good enough and so I think using like
the setting of that
representing a lot of what's wrong with
Society
and reflecting it with the separation of
the rich it's pretty cool yeah there's a
lot of cool things about it it was and
it's tight setting of a good acting
throughout man I thought Nicholas Holt
was a blast
he was so fun I thought John link was
almost really good too he was great I
thought he was excellent yeah no I mean
John like he's he's the best because
he'll show up in every kind of movie but
he's always really committed well I like
that he you know presents himself like
he's the [ __ ] but then he just slowly
peels back that he's the furthest thing
from being the [ __ ] yeah he's just
shitty you know yeah totally and I
thought that was great
um but I liked seeing Arturo Castro get
such a kind of focal side character
because I've been a fan of him since
seeing his Comedy Central show I never
would have expected to see him in a
place like this and I think he's comedy
director sure yeah yeah and I mean like
there there is I mean John Leguizamo has
a good amount of comedy in his
background too and you said Hong Chow is
is funny yes
um but yeah like I I I was just kind of
Charmed and pleasantly surprised by like
oh yeah like I buy this guy like as well
cast his his comedic chops are well
placed here
um but yeah like they cast across the
board even even the actors whose faces I
know and don't really like the critic
and the magazine guy like everybody was
really distinct for the most part even
if you don't really get to know many of
them beyond the types that they are
and uh you know just let the the
construction of the menu was really well
done and the way they intercut these
like food something higher grade than
Food Network but you know like the the
actual like oh it kind of looks like a
cooking show now where you're doing an
insert on the dish and it's explaining
what it is like it had just enough
flourish but without feeling like too
much of a fun house or like you know
like we're having too much like the
style and the presentation of the movie
is very restrained as to match the menu
itself yeah I felt like some parts in
the the first like half hour with its
editing was a little off to me and my
play differently on a on a second
viewing but I thought this first go
around it was a little it was a little
there were times where I was like I
could do with a tad different pacing
because I'm I'm just kind of keeping up
with the amount of cutting we're doing
versus
sinking into the mood of it and there's
a but it eventually got me I was like
pretty much eyes glued to the screen for
the whole time I was really into it but
that's like a really small thing here I
didn't like
I really enjoyed everyone and I I wasn't
I wouldn't be be honest I wouldn't be
bummed if any like I wasn't bummed at
the fact of all them dying yeah like
like none of it I was when they said
they're gonna die I'm like oh good I
hope they all die
I hope the movie goes there I hope the
movie lets them die and I like they
didn't go down a generic route
of Anya Taylor Joy figuring out how to
get everyone out of here yeah yeah yeah
I thought that's where they might go
yeah there's a big distinction that that
looms between her and everybody else
yeah yeah and I just what I found really
unique was the was the interpretation
the execution of the chef character
because this is all
again any other movie I feel like
wouldn't have made it so character based
and why he's doing what he's doing but
there is something that is so despairing
about his portrayal
and self-pitying at the same time you
know and I I love that everything we're
watching is because of this man's uh
failure to enjoy success
sure yeah and to remain connected to his
passions and his goals and why yeah yeah
yeah it's like it's all he's lost sight
of so much and they do touch on like
almost everything you know with uh the
idea of servitude they comment a little
bit on the metoo movement as well yeah
sexual harassment
um you know uh that you know I saw Will
Ferrell and Adam McKay produced it I was
like oh the whole thing with like
corporate greed scheming and yeah faked
uh yeah the the tortilla faked uh
transaction records and stuff like that
yeah I think that they could have
definitely gone down a more cliche path
with every character but they didn't you
know even the three Bros I I thought we
were like okay here we go they were
about to the movie hates these guys are
especially with three alpha males but
the the actors they chose they I thought
brought a lot of like surprise it was in
the scene with Hong Chao is refusing to
give them bread which is a choice by the
way that I loved yeah I loved that they
didn't give them bread because
it's beyond the fact that it's such a
common Association you know like with a
restaurant like hey you get bread it's
just that's just what you get but you
know pulling it back with how this is
what poor people survived off of and
you're you're supposed to be better than
that right yeah yeah but the fact that
they still clamor for it when they have
all these rich Delights that they
entitled to it yeah as much as they want
as much as they need it they're still
they lose sight of like what that bread
actually kind of represents yeah you
know but there's also something to be
said with like they don't really talk
about it but I feel like a lot of
restaurants are like you get so much
bread you get unlimited bread like it's
kind of a greed filled plate of the easy
thing to like give it yeah and a lot of
times it's like you know you get full
before you even get the food because
you're just stocked up on so much bread
and I love that I love that about
restaurants I hope they never change
that Cheesecake Factory Olive Garden
almost every Italian restaurant
bread non-stop bread free bread
it's the best dipping in oil and vinegar
I'm craving it right now as I'm talking
about it I don't know what part of this
food movie made me go I want that but
except for the fries but bread
oil and vinegar it's delicious yeah and
I think too I mean it's good music too
by the way yeah yeah really well done
elegant haunting music and I mean I like
that yeah I like the way it skewers the
restaurant and cuisine just subset of of
people and the way even like Nicholas
hold at the beginning like slags off
every other kind of art as being useless
um but two I've often heard it said that
like you know any and all cooking movies
to some degree can be sort of used as a
also metaphor for filmmaking and I
wonder that's that's part of why I was
wondering why the direct how many films
or what kind of films this director had
done prior because I I have to I just
have to feel like there is some element
here of the struggle when it comes to
really any kind of art form but I'm sure
Cinema because it is such a both because
you can get very hoity-toity high class
about something that is a more populist
art form in general much like the bread
and so you know I think this is nice
because
this has a good array between its
characters of like little microcosms of
themery like there's the big overarching
like yeah class yeah and uh and
you know commodification and all those
things but I think it's it does well in
the life of its other characters and
stuff too yeah have a tapestry that I
think you could draw multiple threads
out of rather than just one major one
and uh I think that's just a nice sort
of uh earmark when you can do that with
a movie like this it's like it's good
enough I think to have you know this
sort of haves versus have-nots ideology
and exploration but to you know then
give it
its own twist depending on which of each
of the characters like the mom isn't
technically part of this set she is just
you know a an aspect of Chef's Life in a
cycle of abuse that she was never able
to break which is a whole other thing
you know and the fact that she's being
punished for it in this way is is an
interesting one and it's it's stuff like
that that doesn't necessarily fully go
into the overall uh the one percent is
terrible
um that I think you know I like when
yeah when they can kind of imbue
different stuff like that when they take
the time because they don't have it but
he but for who he is he blames her sure
yeah you know yeah and again like this
is all chefs like the menu is the chef's
menu you know it's all script it's all
perfectly curated and that greed comes
in many forms I think and even with the
cup the guy who lost his finger uh that
the dude who was constantly cheating on
his wife
you know it's and I like how this movie
lets you kind of Imagine a little bit of
backstory with people versus telling you
yeah like Nicholas Holtz I kind of just
filled that in that's sort of what seems
like it's in his performance of spoiled
rich kid
um because this guy doesn't look like
he's [ __ ] Hernandez and then even
with the old couple I imagine like they
he was once not super successful sure
and he probably grew in success with her
and then and it wasn't good enough so
his relationship's not good enough his
wife's not good enough so he starts
seeking it elsewhere yeah you know I I
think that's I guess it was a fun it's a
fun stuff happening here it's a fun
movie yeah more fun and on Taylor Joy is
great as always she's always good even
yeah I can't think of the time I bought
you was bad no she's I've thought of
things that she's been underused yeah I
can't think of times where I'm like
she's she sucks and she's great again
and uh a perfect I love how her how her
character unfolds
allowing allowing the opening at the
very end
poor people win a movie that was
produced by people with money
I mean like my favorite favorite thing I
do often wonder like yeah it's like how
big of a budget movie can you be like
this had to cost money for the Stars
anyway and how much do you how much do
you think about that when you sign on
you're like I just read this great
script about classism now where's my
million dollars
yeah but but too like I liked it on you
Taylor Joy even in being so is not made
out to be like the immaculate perfect
Saint poor girl she's just kind of like
a real feeling person and she's the most
sympathetic but the movie doesn't
necessarily thrust her to you as like
full-on 100 agreeable audience Cipher
character I mean even though she's like
a hired escort as well she's not played
like you're a [ __ ] you do what I want
you know well yeah and it's like if you
didn't if they didn't touch on that in
the dialogue you could not even you you
wouldn't necessarily have to even
interpret it that way yeah yeah yeah
it's just like you got unlucky and you
got swapped in probably this girl dumped
this guy and now you're here we have
everything we've said the one thing we
haven't said which I'm so surprised we
haven't said is Ray finds it's really
phenomenal oh yeah like there's a guy
who's played that that guy's played so
many villains by this point and that was
part of my lack of interest in watching
this was I already finds as a villain
again okay sure uh I'm like like that's
not Saving Private Ryan for the first
time reaches I'm like yeah he's the
villain and really and uh no I've seen
him Saving Private Ryan I'm just I
thought you had seen it
yes what
you said you saw savior Ryan uh uh
Schindler's List
okay yeah
um yeah and
um the and then of course Voldemort and
like the countless
red dragon the list comes on and off Ray
finds as a villain and I really love how
he doesn't play it like he's having fun
with his food here he really plays it
like a tortured soul and a guy who's
like clinically lost his mind and is
depressed like he's a dude he's really
depressed who's resigned to this yeah
it's very it's a very solemn performance
and uh with a smile that feels so put on
versus
um ladybird versus evil Glee what like
there's he doesn't play it evil and it
was so cool to see him play it very
human like a full-on character and to
bring something refreshing to to to care
to a role that there's very many generic
ways you could have done it and and Ray
finds brings something so special here
and I think after some decades I'd say
you're playing villains he manages to
bring something very unique once again
that doesn't feel repetitive or pulled
from like I've seen Ray fines do this
before because as much as he's the
villain the furthest thing he does is
play it as a villain and I think that's
awesome right down to the the greatest
game uh that's another great amount of
classes of metaphor oh the the most
that's happened yeah the most dangerous
game have the rich people run yeah
well and that's uh I I appreciate too
that that could that's an aspect of
these movies where yeah like whoever's
gonna figure out the game they have some
kind of
eye to eye moment moment of mutual
respect and I liked the way they drew
that here because it did not at all feel
hackneyed or like we just need this to
happen because of the script like the
way they played the connection and the
in like the Curiosity between and then
the ultimate not connection but just the
way that they kind of see one another
Margot and and uh and the chef I thought
was really nicely done too because
that's an aspect that could easily
become cliched or or read as
you know a contrivance and I thought
they made a nice just they made nice out
of that here they made something kind of
Rich out of that here and so when it's
like he doesn't get the Redemption at
the end but it is like you you buy that
last glimmer of like
you did beat me at my own game and in
the process you brought me something I
never thought I would feel again and now
it almost gives his eventual death and
completion of the menu sort of a a bit
of relief yeah yeah so it's like it's I
thought they made interesting stuff out
of most every choice like at every turn
when I thought it could rest on being
just a fun there's something often very
fun about a you know dark satire I feel
like I feel like often these kinds of
movies come with a gleeful sort of
energy to watch people be poked and
prodded and I thought that this movie
actually didn't give in to that and it's
not always even a bad thing but I'm glad
they didn't hear like there is a Glee
and there is a dark humor going on
behind the camera but it's so restrained
that it lets the characters all just
breathe as they are and I think that's a
tremendous asset to an experience like
this one million percent I enjoyed it
yep enjoyed it four to five I would
order it again in fact
and eat it on a rock locally sourced
all right guys well what did you think
about the menu do you agree are you rich
throwing your raw steak at the menu your
HBO Max subscription that's right your
ad free top tier HBO Max
that you're watching on your solid gold
iPad hey let's shout out
someone from our patreon page
aniso liver Anisa
I would like to cook for you oh you know
what I would make you I would first get
a toaster
then I would put two slices of bread in
there oh
and I'd slowly walk over to my cabinet
whilst the bread is toasting private
reserve bread pull out
a jar of peanut butter
open it put my fingers in
taste it oh not wash my hands put that
in my fingers back in that peanut butter
spread it on the bread
then I go back in the fridge the saliva
brings it together grab some mustard
[Music]
put my whole hand in the mustard jar
sweet and Tart I'll lick my whole hand
put it on the other slice of bread
then
I'd
fold those pieces of bread together look
at that that's a new invention
I'm out of knives so I would tear it in
half rip it
now keep in mind it's all toasty so it's
just gonna like crumble everywhere it's
gonna melt on the floor it's been really
messy you're gonna eat it off the floor
then I drop it on the floor and I say
eat this [ __ ] Anisa
lap it up say that's how we do it in
Texas
good old floor Witch good old peanut
butter and mustard floor witch peanut
butter mustard sandwich from the floor
from yours truly it needs some that's
what I want to do for you in 2023
I think that's a manageable goal
honestly
I'd fly to Texas just to watch you do
that
um
and we'll bring the bread you just bring
the people no why am I wasting my breath
of course of course if you're gonna make
a trip out for it right now
your bread in fact you can get the plane
ticket too I'm not buying the bread yeah
Chef Greg doesn't stoop to such levels
I'll bring the mustard from California
I'll fly over and grind I got the seeds
myself got a half eaten bottle of
mustard already
them bring it over in the plane
sneak it onto mine
sneak it into your carry-on carry on
risk them taking it for being they were
too much too big I can't detect there's
no ingredients in it there's an empty
mustard bun in there for three years
it's not gonna oh everything is just you
can't register it is
no longer a paste it is a solid we can
heat it up when we get there and then
yeah perfect I love you a Nissan no no
I'm just kidding we'll take you to
Denny's or some [ __ ] I'll take you
for a burger
all right love you
I'm a real no she got me a great wedding
presents
[Music]